hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres rezept aus
dem ofen ich werde über prag eine
polonaise machen und zwar besteht die
bolognese ganz klar aus hackfleisch und
tomaten
und die wird dann später überbacken mit
einer kartoffel kürbis haube und etwas
parmesan käse also wirklich sehr lecker
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten dafür
brauche ich einen kürbis davon 500 gramm
500 gramm geschälte kartoffeln 50 gramm
butter 150 milliliter milch etwas
muskatnuss einen halben teelöffel salz
und pfeffer und für die polonaise
brauche ich 500 fleisch ist vom rind
einen esslöffel olivenöl 1 el
tomatenmark eine zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe
und eine geschälte karotte einen
teelöffel salz einen würfel zucker 400
gramm tomaten stücke aus der dose und
jedoch ein paar gewürze und so habe ich
einen rosmarin stengel einen teelöffel
oregano und jeweils eine prise chili
curry und ich fange jetzt zuerst einmal
an mit kürbis und den kartoffeln weil
die kartoffeln habe ich jetzt bereits
geschält und deswegen auch in wasser
gelegt damit sie nicht frauen werden und
den kürbis den halbiert und schäden
zum chill nehme jetzt ein kleineres
messer und dann steige ich den kürbis
und die kartoffel in kleine stücke
decke müssen die kartoffeln sind
geschnitten
beides jeweils 500 gramm gebe ich da
etwas wasser noch mit treiben und lass
es dann mit geschlossenem deckel etwa 20
minuten kochen bei mittlerer stufe damit
der kürbis und die kartoffeln weich
werden
in der zwischenzeit mache ich schon mal
die bolognese und zwar wird das olivenöl
in einem topf und da kommt das fleisch
ist mit dazu und wird krümelig
angebraten und die zwischenzeit weiter
zu nutzen um die zwiebel die
knoblauchzehe und die karotte fein zu
würfeln
das gemüse gebe ich jetzt mit zum
hackfleisch und brate es wird zwei bis
drei minuten mit
jetzt kommt das tomatenmark noch mit
dazu und bin gerührt und dann lösche ich
jetzt das ganze mit den formaten ab und
geht noch die gewürze mit dazu
jetzt könnt ihr bei bedarf noch wasser
zufügen und das ganze dann etwa 20
minuten einkochen lassen
die polonaise hier noch ein bisschen
köchelt kann ich schon mal die käse soße
vorbereiten für die käse soße brauche
ich einen esslöffel butter einen
esslöffel mehl 150 milliliter milch 100
milliliter wasser einen viertel
teelöffel salz etwas pfeffer muskatnuss
und 50 gramm habe sagt käser geht es
auch ganz einfach ich gehe jetzt butter
und mehl in einen kleinen topf und
machen eine mehlschwitze
jetzt ein bisschen rühren bis vielleicht
trauen wird
dann kann ich die mail spitze mitmischen
wasser ablöschen und auch schon mal salz
zufügen da noch etwas pfeffer und
muskatnuss
und während es hier jetzt kocht kann ich
schon mal den parmesan reiben
die freaks hier noch den käse mit ein
und lass es dann zwei drei minuten
einkochen
den kürbis und die kartoffeln habe ich
jetzt abgegossen die flüssigkeit beweis
man auf kann ich später auch für eine
suppe benutzen und kann jetzt die gemüse
würfel der kleinen und zerstampfen
da kommt jetzt die butter mit rein
mit gebe ich gar nicht die ganze mills
mit rein weil es einfach schon feucht
genug ist und gebe jetzt noch salz
pfeffer muskat und mit dazu
jetzt kann das gericht geschichtet
werden und zwar kommt ganz unten jetzt
die bolognese soße
darüber kommt jetzt das theorie
dann die käse soße
und nochmal 50 gramm geriebener parmesan
geht
jetzt kann die polonaise bei 200 grad
ober unterhitze 25 minuten in den
vorgeheizten backofen
juli
die bolognese ist jetzt fertig so im
ganzen 17 natürlich ziemlich
unspektakulär unspektakulär aus falls
ihr sie etwas hübscher anrichten wollt
könnt ihr sie zum beispiel auch in so
kleinen fähnchen zu bereiten das finde
ich ganz hübsch vor allem hat man dann
immer gleich eine portion durch echt
sehr schön solche richtet ihr mal an und
erlangen da hinten so ist die küche aus
der murat ist gar nicht da hat er macht
karten liegen wahrscheinlich schimpft
soll ich das gesagt habe aber egal
hätte ihn einfach auf seinem instagram
account deswegen darf jetzt erklären mag
nicht die erde essen
sie ist die er da ist ich würde mal
sagen das probieren
und wie schmeckt das freut mich als ich
habe freund schon probiert nachdem
abschmecken und ich fand alle
komponenten sehr lecker zwingen kann
dieses rezept nur super sein
das ist natürlich ein rezept aus der
kategorie schmeckt sehr lecker sieht
aber nicht so gut aus aber ich würde
sagen gemacht dass auf jeden fall mal
nach und gerne können sie natürlich auch
den kürbis weglassen und einfach nur
kartoffelpüree machen oder zum beispiel
auch mit karotten verfeinert oder auch
anderen gemüse- und ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen und bis
zum nächsten mal
ufc vorbei